Good afternoon, John. It is Thursday, January
11th. (sneezes twice)
So I was just watching my video from January
9th. I'm paying the price for not being commensurate
with my values. At some point, while in Detroit,
I met a really — like a tiny chicken. I
don't actually remember this tiny chicken
but I'm almost positive that we had an encounter,
because this tiny chicken has laid tiny eggs
in my head. One here. One here. One here and
one here.
(sniffles)
Those tiny eggs are growing and hatching,
and the baby tiny chickens are feeding on
my brain. They do everything that baby chickens
do. They're cute, they're fuzzy. They poop,
and they eat. They're eating my brain and
their poop is coming out my nose. Fucking
tiny chicken!
Tell me if you seen junk coming out of my
nose, because it'd be really embarrassing
to have that caught on video blog. No, it's
still there! Ahh, there we go. Ha ha! (sniffle)
No junk. No junk coming out of my nose. No.
I think that we should suggest some more punishments
so that we can choose between punishments.
Also, we can have people suggest punishments.
So far all we have is the 500 Miles punishment,
which I'd be totally okay of doing. Honestly,
I think it'd be fun.
So, punishments that I am suggesting today:
Grow your facial hair for one full week and
then wax your chin. Also, there's the Stick
A Needle In My Eye provision. Third on my
list of punishments that I'm suggesting for
today: Give yourself a mohawk. I kind of always
wanted to give myself a mohawk, and I'd really
like an excuse.
I've got a little bit of a problem, and I
was hoping that you or maybe one of our viewers
could help me out. I was going to Detroit,
right, so I figured I'd have a bunch of business
cards printed up. I used an online service,
and I upload my files, and they sent me a
bunch of business cards. I like that. I like,
it's like a nice, sturdy card stock. And on
the back, it's supposed to be like this one,
which I got printed up at Kinko's. But this
one, on the back, says this. And on the front,
says this.
What am I supposed to do with this? Okay,
it's one thing to have one that does that...
What about this many? This many, that are
the same on all the sides. What am I supposed
to do with it? John, viewers: What do I do
with 100 three inch by one-and-a-half inch
cards that say 'ecogeek' on them? So far my
only idea is to tape them all over my face.
(sings) 'I would walk 500 miles and I would
walk 500 more'
See, this is — this is to me not a punishment.
I— I don't know. To me, it's not a punishment.
We sh— we need to come up with better punishments,
is what I'm saying.